i do i do feel that like one thing
especially in a small town where i grew
up well
you're not told anything about being
able to do anything outside of your
small town
you know the the most ambitious thing
you're told about doing is leaving your
town to go to another university town in
the uk
yeah like the thought of being able to
go to a foreign country and study was
like never even brought up to me it was
never even suggested to me that was
not a possibility yeah like no one in my
my uh
school studied abroad like that was not
even mentioned
and now i feel kind of cheated that that
was never mentioned to me yeah
because you know i meet people who
studied in all of these countries and
that was just because their school was
like oh by the way these courses are
available i'm like
why did no one tell me this is my this
is like
maybe it's my teacher's fault i don't
know someone should have told me that
this was an option that i could have
done this is something that you know
there should have been more options told
to me
and so i went into there and i was like
listen
the teachers are gonna tell you stuff
like you know what they're supposed to
tell you
yeah but please do your own research and
check for courses that
interest you check for international
courses check for stuff that's outside
of
what is being told and fed to you
because there are so much more options
that are so interesting
and way more fitting for you yeah like
somebody who hates
engineering like myself who did it was
never really going to get an engineering
job maybe i would i'd realize within two
three years i'd despise it and i would
quit and go
yeah that might have been like a
deadbeat job for yourself yeah it would
have been something i despised right and
that was just because i didn't there was
no other options presented to me
yeah yeah and i i almost feel like the
system was kind of
failed because it didn't tell me
anything i was just told these are the
courses i can do
yeah and or go to mcdonald's see you
buddy yeah and i feel like a lot of
people
do just it's not a case of people don't
want to do this it's just a case of
people just don't know that it's out
there because i i have exactly the same
experience with you
where the only reason i have a more like
understanding about international
culture is because i come from an
international background and it's an
international family you know
because my family flew over from
thailand that's the only reason i knew
but even
even with that background i had no idea
how many
different paths i could have taken in
terms of like study abroad or have
different kind of experiences like that
if you speak fluent english you can go
study in any english-speaking country
yeah yeah
and apply for an international student
yeah and you you'll probably get
accepted
if you're not if you don't have like you
know a [ __ ] criminal background
you'll probably get accepted like
it's and if i don't know that i could
have just gone to america and studied
i'd have done that
yeah 100 that's like one of my biggest
life regrets is the fact that like i got
offered to like go study
in japan for like two months during high
school yeah and i said no
because i was too lazy yeah and now
you're legit the biggest [ __ ] regret
of my life i mean
i think i think i always had the same
opportunity to study abroad when i was
in high school and i'm just i just
didn't take it because i'm like well
none of my mates are taking it so why
would i take it exactly and i'm just
like well
i'm gonna be away from my friends and
family for like three months yeah i
don't want that
instead i went to another [ __ ] welsh
town
yeah and if i knew that was an option i
would have gone for it so that's the
main reason why i went to the school to
talk to these kids was because i was
like
tell these kids you know what the [ __ ]
about the
the kids yeah i thought you know i'd let
them know and just say like yeah
like you can do [ __ ] yeah just do you
can literally do anything you want bro
don't let your dreams be dreams so i
hope
hopefully if one of those kids looked up
and did something and had fun
probably not though i mean because even
even in university there would
there would be like courses where you
know you you'd have the opportunity to
study at one of their like sister
universities
in another country and i remember that
they would like you can tell the kind of
people who
were going to study abroad because like
they just seemed like they were up for
anything
and i was just like man i i wish i had
the balls
that you had back when i was in
university because i feel like that
would have been one of the best
experiences in my life
or just like a really valuable uh
valuable piece of experience that
i just didn't get until later in life
right yeah because i feel like
part of part of like this part of
your life after university and
especially during like your mid to late
30s is that
you kind of realize that life just kind
of stays the same
unless you actively search for new
experiences
and i didn't realize that until after
after university life attended that you
know we were just really lucky
as you know as a kid as a teenager
whatever to just
every year you'd kind of get a new
experience but once that
period of your life is over then you
just have to search for that yourself
and it's just not going to come to you
you got to do that yourself and that's
why like i feel like a lot of people
who we in the same area who we grew up
with they just end up staying
in that same area yeah or they just you
know you go back home and they haven't
changed much right and it's just i'm
just
that's just because they haven't
realized that if they don't do something
then nothing's ever going to change and
some people are comfortable with that
and that's completely fine but i think
there are i've met enough people in my
life who
have have like this urge to do something
new and do something different
don't even know where to get started i
feel like just just go for it just do
you
you miss every shot you don't take right
yeah yeah just just do something out of
your comfort zone yeah
no you don't need an excuse to do
anything just take a risk i remember one
time my friend went
and like traveled what abroad
[ __ ] you can do that yeah yeah just go
somewhere for fun alone
yeah i remember i thought okay i'm kind
of jealous this guy just had the balls
to do that yeah
and now now i wouldn't mind doing that i
i do i wouldn't it's not preferable but
i wouldn't mind doing it
yeah if i want to go somewhere or you
want to do something you don't have an
excuse to do it you [ __ ] go
still yeah like i was thought i remember
i was talking to a guy
um who had you know uh backman
university and
he was talking about this was going in
his 30s he was talking about yeah i used
to work at this big company
uh and then i just quit and saved up and
just traveled for like a year or two and
i'm just like
wait i thought gap gears would i thought
you could
do that after your gap year that's what
gap she has before yeah and he's just
like no
just you know i just did it because i
just needed change in my life and you're
like
wait but what happens when you go back
how what's you have a career right i
just i just couldn't comprehend
someone just doing something out of
the uh the life path that you know the
career path that
i was taught it's like yeah it's like
the moment you have your career it's
like why would you willingly just
end your career why would you just quit
your job
but uh i mean yeah like [ __ ] if i was in
that position i'd probably do it too you
know
yeah sometimes it does take you know
that kind of
massive risk-taking to realize that oh
you know maybe it's [ __ ] worth it to
end your career maybe that career wasn't
worth it
be a youtuber yeah you should just be
like youtubers
i'm just gonna in my career go on a trip
yeah but i feel i feel like especially
this this goes to most like
high schoolers because i feel like
that's that's the point in your life
where you have the most opportunity to
do
something something crazy with your life
not even something crazy just something
out of your comfort zone
something that can you increase your
perspective of what happens just try
some [ __ ] out if it doesn't work out try
some different [ __ ] until it clicks yeah
if you're
about to go to university at some point
and you're maybe looking for courses or
whatever dude look around for like
international stuff or whatever there's
tons out there
anything that's gonna be fun as [ __ ]
yeah trust me like i i remember
the biggest adventure i'd go i'd i had
gone on it's just moving cities to go to
my university town and
as in in england every city is kind of
the same you get you get the kind same
kind of experience you get freshers week
you go drink a [ __ ] ton
it's the same for it was like the same
experience no matter what university i
would have gone to yeah
um and i wish i'd studied abroad i'd
wish i'd done
something new and like i i feel like
after i quit to become a youtuber i i
was like gaining back the gears that i
could have had
if i just got out my comfort zone
earlier in my life yeah i've definitely
been doing that like since
i've gotten like so many opportunities
doing this job i feel like i'm just like
playing a catch-up game of like
i'm taking literally everything that
comes to my doorstep now because yeah
i didn't take any of that [ __ ] yes back
then yeah yeah so i'm like
and now i regret it being like oh [ __ ]
why was i so lazy and dumb to like not
take these like
now that i look at amazing [ __ ]
opportunities now i know that
everything that comes to me even if it
seems dumb or like pointless or whatever
i'm just gonna [ __ ] take it
yeah i mean i let league of legends ruin
my life so i'm just
uh i've been farming far too many hours
in the legal legends and i'm like i want
i want something but you know what i'm
gonna try something else
a pixelation i'm gonna
league of legends i might try happiness
for once i don't know i'll see how it
see what works out for me
see which one i prefer for me
honestly if being happy works out for me